the thing I remember about my first
movie going experience was that I loved
it I think it was Pocahontas Flash
Gordon rocky with my dad Tom Thumb
Pinocchio home alone it's a hard day's
night by the Beatles and America so it's
Bambi Bambi Bambi has a little girl in
Japan - Ichi you dope about the puzzle
cupcake my first movie ever she was
pathetic Young Frankenstein this needs
the rescuers Mary Poppins Mary Poppins
Mary Poppins what Mary pop that was mine
no she floated away and I was crushed
it's a little bit blurry for me my first
movie going experience I think it might
have been crashed over tyson's I believe
I was four and I saw Fantasia psycho I
can't believe my parents let me go see
it's got walls and stones star wars star
wars I don't even remember seeing the
movie I just remember him putting me in
the car
and telling him we're about to see the
most amazing thing you've ever seen in
your life could have been the Wiz [ __ ]
by carpenter it was Hercules the
animation it was Toy Story the very
first Toy Story film The Lion King Lion
King gross
first of a feeling it was probably
Gallipoli alien aliens double-feature
will be call yellow sky the Western in
Spanish it was called koopida motorist
allo which was the Love Bug the Apple
Dumpling gang and I fell asleep taxi
driver I was I think 13 jars I think I
would have been four which would have
been extremely inappropriate for me to
go see a beautiful film called the
silent one little princess by alfonso
cuarón order certain jae-hoon i pay
rs.10 do now sonic go
and begin the curtain as a sound of
music abundant key appears jason and the
argonauts
Cinderella Saturday Night Fever
winnie-the-pooh we rented it so many
times that they ended up giving it to us
for free so I always knew I guess I was
destined for animation my first movie
was crumpled movie Raiders of the Lost
Ark amarcord
for eco Fellini 2001 Douglas Sirk's
Imitation of Life projected singing in
the rain singing in the rain with my
father King Kong the original King Kong
Carrie [ __ ] Spacek and when things
really got bloody I threw up on my
father that's my